the gyro can experience any Bravo what's
happening cocksucker what's that you're
a month away from having a kid you
sitting there like fucking Buddha with
no fucking food
I love ready for this man are you ready
this you gotta be fucking picked a name
yet TV show on discovery I wanted to
tell me you went the uncle's house and
change some diapers a kid for a while
and we tried that you know this was
planned it's gonna be a fascinating
experience
you you a different fucking man for sure
changed me as a human being first it was
the reefer when you came to me you said
you had the best ice cream sundae in
your life yeah any problem the way you
gave it to me that was beautiful and
then next thing you know mrs. Rogan came
on the scene I seen the whole yeah I
will never forget the day Eddie Bravo
got me high we that we went and had ice
cream sundae and I had the most massive
revelation of my life I couldn't believe
how god damn good that ice cream sundae
take me to meet you that was the first
time he ever straightened up before then
you were fucking ape he was still bent
over fight through your banana you need
to fucking peel seriously your back you
will back your chest whazzup shit well
you guys know me I don't know me as well
as you guys know oh please that was you
you will walk on all know imma tell that
fucking I'm a different person I'm a lot
more relaxed and everything but it must
have been interesting much more for you
to watch someone change their
personality with it it's a fucking
beautiful thing man I love to see
evolution i but people watching I love
to watch people show you fucking man you
know don't say that but think coming
from you know my background you know
doing martial arts competitions my whole
life and then just transition right into
comedy I had never relaxed
I never settled down I never I never
learned how to just be calm you know it
was ego my whole body in my brain my
personality all developed under duress
it all developed under
you know a physical combat all the time
on a regular basis constant training
constant fights constant tournaments
that was no that was my life from like
ten mohs 15 till I was like 22 all my
formative years was all spent in in
stress and I remember when I first
decided that I wasn't gonna fight
anymore it's like the first time ever in
my life when I was like 22 it's my last
kick boxing fights I've the first time
ever where I could relax I would always
like be nervous like when is the next
tournament when's the next fight when's
the next thing I gotta get in shape I
can't be drinking this I can't be doing
it I couldn't live my life because I was
always worrying about getting my ass
kicked I was always worrying about like
I have to make sure that I do everything
right I had to be prepared I don't wanna
get fucked up you know so it's like it's
it wasn't the best mindset to go in a
stand-up comedy for that's for sure it's
like a constant battle good stand-up
comedy you got it totally the opposite
you got to not give a fuck you know you
got a you got to be relaxed you got to
have fun don't settle be tense and ready
to go at any moment's notice you know
you sent me by the way whatever Issa
means doesn't work one of them doesn't
work the other two do check her emails
yeah I just you sent me two things and
both of them are like movies that are
one second long what dude I know I know
it's good my father ascended okay
I fucking 15 to 22 my mind wasn't
fighting them I was gonna fight it but I
was in a different type of hell I was in
my own hell I was putting myself into
you know it's so weird and I became a
comic what six seven eight years later
there was something like that and how I
took that wildness into the fucking
comic and nobody understood what I was
saying to my met you guys thought I
found the fucking home I was always I
used to travel on the road with Tribble
and do all these little road remember
when I first met you the store everybody
was fucking terrified of you yeah I was
crazy
nobody knew you and I I remember being
like the only guy like when I first met
you that was like he's great what are
you talking about I love that guy and
there was a girl here comes Joey Diaz
like where's yet I like would gravitate
towards you I was because you didn't
scare me you were nice to me you know it
was you a unit you weren't a scary guy
to me you were a regular dude I could
you were like one of the only guys there
that I could relate to there was like a
lot of guys that I couldn't relate to I
knew dudes like you you know I mean not
you but you and my friend Johnny be the
pool
very similar characters man very very
similar characters you're both way out
there
you both like not give a fuck guys and
you're both guys that were like
polarizing some people would love you to
death and then everybody you know there
was a large group of people but for
whatever reason they'd be upset at you
like I never have to defend you even the
Dahmer era even da Marrero is hating on
you calling everybody everything I don't
yeah and I loved it I fucking loved it
because that's why you know it's so
weird that this whole surgery thing
really taught me about fear my fear has
fucking done wonders for me because
that's why when I wake up in the morning
I stop and do is grab my fucking cock
because for years I was scared
I'm always insecure that immigrant
fucking thing's chiseled into my fucking
mind
since the streets of New York City with
the immigrant thing not knowing the
language not feeling good enough like
everybody else not being a fucking
American and it sits inside my fucking
soul so for me everything has been
written on fear every time I get on
stage like the other night fear was real
in Chicago I got on stage in between the
reefer and whatever was going on in the
lights
I got fearful man but you know what
that's normal to be scared that's a
great emotion especially when you're a
stand-up comic because we're more scared
you are the better you're gonna fucking
do especially in my case the more riled
up I am two minutes before I go onstage
the more energy I'm gonna give that
fucking audience but I've looked at my
life and I've seen how much fear I was
petrified to go get that fucking needle
even though I fucking knew nothing was
gonna happen I was gonna walk out of
there but I went in I took the needle
after I walked out at me like for the
fucking kill ten fucking people with my
bare hands because you overcome one of
your biggest fucking fears till this day
I get little emails and people you know
I suffer I suffer from a social miss
Florida and I don't know what to do with
the answer ain't taking a fucking pill
it's checking your fucking confidence
and grabbing your balls and walking into
a circle insane fucking I'm here you
know my mentality was always going to
little mouth of the line and put a chair
down and sit the fuck down and let the
pieces fall where they may and if you're
not gonna live like that fucking more
I'm at the store two fuckin nights joe
rogan the first fucking night Eddie
Griffin bumps me you know how
embarrassing it is you become a regular
on a Sunday the first fucking night EULA
eleven people come see you your landlord
comes and you get bumped by Eddie
Griffin and the second night I go up
there and Steve Greenstein says to me
hey last weekend you fucking audition
here for missing you said one of my
jokes I said it's February fucking 11th
I just come off a plane January 29th and
you're already accusing me of being a
fucking thief remember he had his violin
case
who Steve Greenstein I don't remember it
was a creepy guy older guy that hung at
the Comedy Store he had a violin case so
this is a Tuesday night it's black night
at the Comedy Store it's eight o'clock
the main room is packed but the original
room would be empty because people were
scared to go up there on black night to
the duck they were gonna get fucking mug
so the original room was always empty so
Steve Greenstein was up before me he get
this is my second night the comedy stood
dog I just got that way I'm a fucking
criminal I've been in prison I got all
these problems but for the first time my
life I got a little fucking daylight The
Comedy Store this lady made me a regular
all my life people were like cause
Mickey Shore seeing you as Mickey sure
seeing you she gonna make you a fucking
regular I get down there I'm a regular
the first time since my mother died I
had any luck that been in prison I'd
been divorced you know shot I get the
whole fucking deal
next thing you know I become a regular
it's Tuesday night and I get off stage
and I'm waiting to hang out for a little
while and Steve Greenstein comes up to
me and he says to me Doug one of your
jokes is like my joke I said which one
is this all about budge oj simpson is
made I got drunk I didn't steal the joke
from you I just fucking got here two
weeks ago wheels comes out he goes this
guy didn't steal the joke from you the
only problem was the guy put the violin
case behind his fucking legs when I
spotted it so he's not threatening he's
like dog the next time you do that joke
we're gonna have a problem I just pushed
him Joe Rogan he fell over the violin
case boys he's falling down Mitzi's limo
pulls up that's it I'm like I'm done
this is my life I'm fucking gone out of
here I'm never gonna get another fucking
spot again I'm gonna go back to selling
fucking blow and wheels got between us
Scott day got between us and Mitch he
came on go what happened here
and he started saying he goes no this
kid's Cuban Baba and but mitzi seen the
kid on the floor and fell in love with
me after that cuz I pushed that
motherfucker you like thumbs up for
myself
you got lucky she was crazy sure she
liked the fuckin improv I would have
been out of the fucking Street how often
did you perform at the improv
not in those days in those days every
week because the the guy Richard Cooper
loved me the talent coordinator but I
got to LA January 29 that was a regular
after-school February 19th on my
birthday I didn't fuck around this town
when I got it
but you couldn't do the improv admits he
found out but I went to Scott dance a
dog Richard Cooper gives me spots so I
would go over there and I had a couple
problems over there right off the
fucking bat people talk to every kid
over there you know you leave your
fucking girlfriend others eat you gonna
bat when you come back they're talking
for them like they know that is it and
you know it's a fucking issue you gotta
you got to stop them like I told you
like Hitler in Munich there's not you're
gonna have a fucking problem dog so I
would say things to people no I'm saying
you're a bad fucking person
so what the fuck I don't give a fuck and
we're here twelve years later and we're
still rocking and rolling it still
sucking my dick and call me shorty
[Applause]